>> DFB: It's a great pleasure today to welcome back
an old friend - Professor Brian Kernighan, now of
Princeton University, previously at Bell
Labs. For those of you who would like to know
how we met in the first instance, we have
already prepared a Computerphile video on
this very topic. You can refer to the
"Great 202 Jailbreak" which is all about
computerized typesetting in the very
early 1980s. So, welcome back
Brian! It's only been 30-odd years
since you last spoke to us here.
And we're delighted to have you here in the more
intimate "Computerphile" context.
Perhaps I could begin by asking you, just a little
bit, about "What was it like to work at Bell Labs. ?"
>> BWK: Right, so first let me say it's actually a
pleasure to be back at Nottingham and
this is not the same digs as you had 30-odd years ago.
It's definitely fun to be back.  What
was it like at Bell Labs.? Well I first
went to Bell Labs., I think, in 1967,
I had ... I was at the time a graduate
student in computer science, except it
was before computer science - it was
electrical engineering at Princeton and
I was lucky enough to get a summer job
at Bell Labs and so I spent two summers
there actually working on a couple of
different things - one of which became my
thesis. But it was a wonderful place
because there were an enormous number of
really good people doing really
interesting things and nobody telling
you what to do. That's kind of a rewarding
environment and so it was so good that
when I graduated from Princeton I didn't
even interview any other place. I just said "OK
I'll go to Bell Labs, they offered me a job
why not do it?". And that was a decision that
was extremely lucky, and I've
never regretted it. What it was like was,
I would guess that in one single large-ish
building then we're probably 4,000
people, of whom about 2,000 were
probably PhD's in various forms of
science: physics, chemistry and materials
and then on - call it the 'softer' end -
of mathematics and the relatively new field of
computer science, at that point.
A large number of really, really excellent
people and the environment was "You can
do anything you want" because the revenue
source for Bell Labs was very stable.
It was part of AT&T which, in effect,
provided telephone service for the whole
country and the way it did it at that time
... AT&T was a regulated monopoly which
meant that they had in effect a
guaranteed rate of return and they
peeled a tiny piece of that off for
research to improve telephone service in
the country - that was the quid pro quo.
And because of that there was no
shortage of resources and no management
direction that said you have to do
something that will save the company in
the next quarter. That was really very
satisfying and so most people worked on
things that were in some way long term,
or at least whose immediate application
wasn't obvious. Hard to beat that
environment, I think, and I think I was
there for over 30 years and I was never
once told what I should be working on.
The way it worked was, at the end of each
year, you had to write down on one side
of one piece of paper what you had done
during the year and they used that to
determine how much they'd pay you next year.
>> DFB: So, I'm all in favour of this benevolent
monopoly environment because, after all, it gave
us UNIX.
And as we all know UNIX changed everything.
it really, really did in the computer science field
But one of the recurring themes of all your work
over the years was, if you like, little languages and
software tools. In the "202 Jailbreak" movie
I think I referred to your "pic", y' know,
the little pre-processor for doing line-diagrams within
typeset documents. But that's by no means the only one,
so, again, was this just you
or was there a lot of mutual interest in the little
languages - things joined together with UNIX pipelines -
that sort of approach?
>> BWK: I that the interest was perhaps latent there
and then when
the pipeline mechanism was invented
- which was some combination of Doug
McIlroy with an idea and Ken Thompson
with an implementation - when that came
along people started to think more
consciously of how you could combine
programs so that this program could do
something and produce output that went to
this program, and the combination would
do something richer and more interesting.
I think it's hard to see ... in particular
that showed up in some of the document
preparation tools fairly early on
because, among other things, there were
limits on how big a program could be.
This was ... hard to think back that far but
a big machine at the time would have 64
Kbytes - Kbytes by the way, not
Mbytes or Gbytes - and so that meant that
any individual program could not
actually be very big and so there was a
natural tendency to write small programs
and then the pipe mechanism and
basically input-output redirection made it
possible to link one program to another.
And certainly for the work that Lorinda Cherry
and I did on 'eqn' - which was a language for
typesetting mathematical expressions - the
existing formatting program 'troff'
precursor of things like TEX today -
that was already a big program by the
standards of the time; it just barely fit
in to the memory for user programs and so
adding more to it was not feasible, you
couldn't actually do it. And so what we
did instead was to create an entirely
separate program connect them with a
pipeline and then if the program is
going to be separate you could have it
represent - recognize - a different language.
It doesn't have to actually do the same
language because it's a separate program
and I think that that was a place where,
perhaps, necessity was the mother of
invention that it actually worked out
quite well and then further document
preparation programs - you mentioned 'pic'
a moment ago -
further document preparation programs
had that same property that they were
separate programs, separate languages,
tailored to the particular job that they
were trying to do. And so that separation of
concerns worked out really well forced on us,
in some ways, by not having very much in
the way of computing resources.
>> DFB: So although it was forced upon you, was there
a great sense of surprise about  "Wow! you actually gain
power and flexibility doing it this way"
>> BWK: Yeah - and I think people started to think
I know I remember fairly clearly at this
point that when the pipe mechanism was
first invented - and it was literally
not more than a day or so of existence,
in some sense, people started to say "Hey!
wait a minute - this is very easy we can
connect programs together. But we may
have to change the way the programs are
implemented, in a trivial way, so that
they read from their standard input -
guaranteed - they write to their standard
output - guaranteed - and then you can glue
them together". And then there was this burst
of making straightforward changes to the programs
so that they would fit in pipelines and then
people doing interesting pipelines with them
inventing crazy combinations that did things.
One of the finest examples was one that
Steve Johnson did for finding spelling
mistakes - potential spelling mistakes - in
the document. You take a document; you
convert into words - that's one program.
You sort the words that's another
program; you compare them against the
dictionary - that's another program and
you print the ones that are in the
document but not in the dictionary. And
that's another program, and so this multi-
element pipeline was our first cut at a
spelling mistake detection program.
>> DFB: Good heavens! Yeah! I suppose the
thing you also have to learn, as I found to my
cost - by experience, is you've got to be somewhat
careful when a thing has to be in a pipeline
but has to be transparent, y'know, when you've
always got to think
about how might what I'm sending down the
line foul up by being picked up too early
by something that I didn't expect. But there
again - small price to pay.
>> BWK: But there's a nice example of that in
sorting - if you think about it - if
you have a sort program in the middle of a
pipeline it's a full-stop, because the downstream
programs can't do anything else until
the sort program has done its job
because it has to see all the input
before it can sort. But the fact that
it's a full-stop doesn't matter to the user
- it looks like it's just a continuous
process - and so the packaging of that
it actually quite important - to do it well.
>> DFB: I think when I first came to UNIX I was
pretty familiar with the idea of what
used to be called the job-control interpreter
so there was no great surprise in
encountering the UNIX 'shell'. But again, by
the time we're talking about late version 6 UNIX,
version 7 - late '70s early '80s - all of
a sudden it was as if, from nowhere, you'd got
the idea of other flexible interpreted
languages and I'm thinking of course,
primarily, of Awk So how did that come about?
>> BWK: Right, so I think part
of it - you mentioned the shells - I think
part of it comes about because the
shells were used to combine programs and
you could do other things with the data
as it was passing through, in a very
simple way. But the shells were not very
good programming languages and so you wanted
to do more with them.
Awk itself had three or four different
inspirations, I think, one of them not as
well advertised at this point, I guess,
was a language done by Mark Rochkind in
which he had designed a language for validating
data that was  ...  came from telephone
switching systems - or something like that -
where all it did was to look for
patterns of input and when it saw a
line that matched one of those patterns
it printed it because it was ... or  perhaps
didn't match it ... it was some kind of error
It was in effect a very simple streaming program.
So that would be one influence from the outside and
I had been interested in somehow having a
programming tool -  some kind of tool - where
I could manipulate text and numbers more
or less together - kind of  equally easily. C programs
were good at numbers but very bad at
text and the shell wasn't really very
good at text and terrible at numbers. So I
was kind of interested in that sort of
thing. Al Aho, who was in the office
next to me,  was very interested in
regular expression technology' He'd just
finished 'egrep' which is an extended
version of 'grep' - a much richer set
of regular expressions and very
efficient implementation. Peter
Weinberger, who was on the other side of
Al, was very interested in database-
related things he had just finished doing
a tiny relational database for UNIX. So
here's this combination of three people,
right together, interested in things
that sort of loosely are related to each
other, but not much, and so we started
talking about what do you want, what
could we do, what could we build here,
that would be an interesting tool and
in some weird way it's a generalization of
'grep' and 'sed'. It includes a much richer
set of regular expression stuff and there's
this database flavour. Peter knew about
RPG, a report generator thing, and so I
don't whether you'd call it the great
combination, or the mishmash, of these
things, put together, led us to designing
'awk' and then doing the first implementation. It
wasn't a great deal of work I think at this
point, if my memory is right, Peter did the
first implementation of it over a
weekend - 3 or 4 days at most. A lot of it was
easy because we had the right tools at
hand, in particular we had 'yacc' which was
the parser-generator that Steve
Johnson and Al Aho had built. That made it easy
to define the syntax of the language so
that you could parse statements in that
language and then you could hang
semantic actions on it and that
existence of 'yacc' led to a whole bunch of
different interesting tools in the UNIX
environment;  'eqn' which we talked about
a few moments ago was done with 'yacc', for
example;  'pic' which you mentioned was done
with 'yacc'. So, it was a very very effective
tool for building new languages and so
that's another reason why I think people
thought in terms of language. "I've a tool
that makes it easy to build language - so
let me just do it."
>> DFB: My memory is of the sort of
feeling of liberation,
of setting up a 'sed' and 'awk' pipeline, driven
from the shell, I just thought it was absolutely
great. And yet there seemed out in the big wide world
- although there was a lot of admiration for the work
you did - that some people felt that re-integration might
be a  positive advantage. I'm thinking, of course, of 'perl'.
What's your take on this sort of tradeoff, if you like,
between having everything integrated so that all the
communication between what's happening
is internal and therefore perhaps "more efficient"  in
quotes - I don't know - versus doing it the pipeline way?
>> BWK: I think it's a tradeoff !
I think is precisely a tradeoff that
there's no single right answer. It
depends on the application. There's some
things for which a quick and dirty
sequence of separate programs works really
well. You just do it - you're done - you
don't have to think about it. If you're doing
something more complicated, perhaps
something which is going to last longer,
then integrating it into a single
program is probably a better choice but
without looking at a particular
situation I don't think I would know
which one to use. 'Perl' was definitely
built as a reaction to 'awk';  'awk' had
a lot of limitations at the time and some
of the limitations were artificial
because the version that we were using
internally was not the version that was
available outside. AT&T in its wisdom
decided that they wouldn't release the
richer version and so some of what
Larry Wall did would have been
obviated by a newer version of 'awk', but
then of course he added an enormous number
very useful features to it and made it a
much richer scripting language and one which
you could build bigger programs. I think
one of the issues for all of this is
"How big is the ultimate program going to
be, or even the one that you're building
right away"?  If you're doing something
that's only a couple of lines long 'awk'
is great. I mean it really is. I don't think
anything beats it for one liners - and
where "one" is a metaphor for "two or
three". But when you get bigger than that
it doesn't scale very well because it
doesn't have any of the things that prevent
you from doing something stupid - or, at least,
finding out when you did - and so, for
bigger programs, you want something that
has more going for it. I think what's
going on in modern programming language
is this more and more that kind of ...
>> DFB: Yeah! I think I can see a little bit of that ...
What I loved about it, of course, was its pattern-matching ability
and then matching that pattern you took
that action but again, I found the hard way, that
what can be sometimes rather awkward is if in
the combined script you have two distinct
routes through it -
for two distinct purposes. It can be very difficult,
sometimes, disentangling those when things go
wrong as inevitably they do.
>> BWK: The pattern-action paradigm is really, really good it
is a great model for certain kinds of
computation; 'grap' is a pattern-action
program; 'sed' is a pattern-action
program; 'yacc' is a pattern-action program
'lex' - all of those tools have that same
model.  Here's some patterns and you read the
input and if it pattern-matches, do the
corresponding action. So they're all
great but there are plenty of things
that don't fall into that. If you want to
make two passes over something, or if you
gotta remember complicated state it doesn't
work as well. And what I've discovered
when I write 'awk' programs is often
rather than trying to figure out how to
keep track of state from one
line to another on the input, I read the
whole input into a giant array and then
do traditional indexing computations on
the array. It's just easier.
>> DFB: Yeah! And again, adding the
associative facility in that array that you can
index into it via strings, and so on  - that's
another big plus as well.
But this business of you having a powerful
version of what you're doing at Bell Labs but
the powers-that-be deciding
supposedly, I guess, under very great stress
of external pressure, as to exactly what should be
released, with a UNIX release to the outside world,
on the usual basis, from what I gather, that it's
just not fair, say the other
computer companies - you've got all these bright
people producing this stuff but they're cross-subsidised
from our telephone bills. Were you, as a research
community aware of that problem  all the time?
>> BWK: We were certainly aware of it. I don't think
we paid a tremendous amount of attention to
it, but it came up from time to time. It came up
... I think the reason that the 'awk' version
where the official mechanism didn't want
to release a newer version of 'awk' was
a perfectly legitimate concern with
standardization. You want to have
something that other people can count on
its behaviour and properties. If you put out
a new version - now you have two versions -
and there's potential confusion in the
market and they weren't ready to do that.
So it was a combination of trying to
present a unified version of something
and then wanting to actually own what it
was that they were putting out and
supporting. So I think that one was
legitimate. The cross subsidy issue, I
think, for people in research, basically
didn't really show up. It was much more of
a legal concern and I think most of
what was going on in our particular
domain was sufficiently down in the
noise that it didn't affect us. It did,
probably, affect the people who were
doing UNIX commercially - which was not
the research people - but the research
people started with what had been done
... sorry, the commercialization people started
with what had been done in research and
then, of course, added
lots of things that made it a better
commercial product. And they definitely, at
various time,s had to worry about this
cross-subsidy
issue. It comes back to the fact that AT&T
was a regulated public monopoly, getting
a guaranteed rate of return on their
investments and so, yes, are you cross
subsidizing by competing using money that other
people were forced to buy your product with.
>> DFB: Yes, I remember well going to
presentations about our licensing terms for
UNIX - and being warned about how careful we had
to be, not to let commercial usage get mixed in with
our educational usage, and so on.
But do you think, in the end, that had that not
been so restrictive and onerous by AT&T, that the
need to develop Linux might not ever have occurred?
>> BWK: That is an excellent question
I don't think I have an answer - certainly not an
informed or accurate answer. I think probably if there
had been the equivalent of open source,
at the time, really open source, then
perhaps there would be less different
versions of UNIX floating around and
there might be not be one done by this really
bright student in Finland. Yeah, I think possibly
that would have changed the game because
I know that some of the software
development - associated with UNIX broadly -
was people trying to go around the AT&T
licensing considerations.
>> DFB: Yeah, Of course we encountered that in our
typesetting adventures that, basically, the whole business
of reverse-engineering, jailbreaking, whatever you want
to call it - that you
did was really motivated by the fact
that the whole concept of "Open-ness" just
wasn't there, in the '70s and '80s. You just
had to have closed systems, There was no way out of it.
Did you realize, at the time, how pioneering you were
being, in a way, about all of this?
>> BWK: No, I don't think so, certainly not on the
typesetting front, where I don't think it
was pioneering. It was simply trying to
remove an impediment. We couldn't use the
typesetter with the software that came with it.
It was unusable. And so, again of necessity, we had to
do something to make it so that we could
actually do what we wanted to do, because
their software systems weren't up to what we
wanted to do. More broadly, the openness
that you see today, in language design
and operating systems and so on, I don't
think we predicted that in any way
either. Not clear how you make money
doing that and of course a lot of
systems at the time - certainly in the
seventies and eighties this was the
lifeblood of the companies that provided
the service and so they couldn't just
give it away and make it back in ...
What do you make it back in?  Public relations?
>> DFB: No you have to make it back by turning
yourself and saying "You can get the free
open version but if you want really good backup
we're the people to give it." But, of course,
that's not a stance that companies were prepared to
take in those days.
Again, I mean, as we both know, it happened with
computer hardware -  it certainly happened again with
typesetting hardware. They  could not envisage a scene
where they didn't sell the hardware bundled with
the software.
>> BWK: That certainly was the model for a long
long time, and in fact in early days, the IBM days,
let's say in the '60s and '70s
IBM made all of their money on the
hardware and the software was kind of
given away as part of it.
>> DFB: Yes it was all sorts of
ramifications over this side of the Atlantic
about "When will IBM be forced to unbundle?"
I remember the word very clearly indeed. Aanyway,
after 'awk' I get the impression that then, over
the next few years, you moved into other areas of
interest that had been around for a while - things
like tcl / tk, which I've never used, so could you say
something about that?
>> BWK: Yeah, tcl / tk is really two pieces.
This is just wonderful work by John Ousterhout
who, at the time, was at Berkeley; now at Stanford.
And what John did with 'tcl', TCL, the tool
control language which was basically an
interpreted language, a scripting
language if you like, that made it very
easy to extend by adding C functions so
that the essence of it was that you
could write code in this, but you would
be mostly calling functions that have
been written in C. As a language it's
bizarre and I've told John that
on a number of occasions but it was very
very powerful you could actually do a lot with it and
then 'tk' was an instance of a set of C
functions that would do something
interesting. And it was basically a set
of graphics routines that worked with
X11, so that you could very easily draw
things of real complexity and richness on a
screen. I think as a graphics package it
is a great improvement on all of its
successors. It's just a remarkably
efficient, effective and rich environment.
So I used that for a number of years, doing
quick and dirty user interfaces for a
variety of things and even one that was
used for a while inside Bell Labs. There was
a project, ill-conceived I think, at least
in retrospect, for doing wireless
systems that would work well inside
buildings -  especially big buildings
- like hospitals and big stores. And so
to do that you need something that will tell
you how electromagnetic radiation propagates
within the building, so you have an
elaborate model for EM propagation. You have
to know where things are in the buildings
where are  the walls, what are they made of, what
are the floors - all of that kind of thing
and then, from that, you can say "If I put
base station equipment - routers if you like -
in various places in the building then I can
figure out what the coverage in the
building is. But that's all kind of low-level,
radio, sort of thing. How do you make that
accessible to somebody who might be, y'know,
an engineer trying to design this stuff or
somebody with not any of the real radio
background? And so what we did was to
design a system that had all of that
prediction of propagation models and on
top of that a user interface which would
show you
slices through the building; show you where the
walls were - and things like that - and say "If
you put a base station there this is what
the propagation is gonna look like over
the building". And then. in addition, we
could even optimize
that so that it would tell you "This is
where you ought to put the base stations
given the number you propose to do". And I
wrote that user interface. That was
my part of it. I wrote that user
interface in tcl / tk it was really,
really effective and surprisingly easy. I
remember being on a conference call with
some people who were the ultimate users -
intended users - of the system and they
said "You know, we really need a feature
to do something." I don't remember what the
feature was and they kept talking about
the feature during the conference call.
And while they were doing it I was
sitting in my office. I implemented it
in 'tk' - because it was just so easy. It was really, really great
>> DFB: So, this was your transition into the world of graphics
and graphics terminals in a way?
>> BWK: Because early in those days, yeah, because we
finally had terminals that weren't just text.
>> DFB: Exactly! And I think one of the
things that was of interest -  great interest - to
us. You could see the huge strength of UNIX in
the days of dumb terminals, if you like. But how was it
going to cope with the great graphics onslaught in the
late '80s? Now I think, looking back on it, there were
all sorts of
internal projects on your own terminals, and so on,
were there not?
>> BWK: Yeah, we had weird terminals.
The one that I remember most clearly
was the Tektronix 4014 ?? - some random
number -  I can't remember. There's lots of
random numbers in computing! But it was a big thing
big green screen. But it had a sort
of vector graphics kind of thing where
you could draw lines. You couldn't do
much beyond that - no shading or anything.
So there were some graphics done with
that and then eventually we started to
get color terminals that were bitmap, not
vector and so there was a lot of interest in
software to drive those sorts of things.
I didn't do very much of that by that
point I was using other people's
libraries because that's a specialized technical
area - to do that well.
>> DFB: But in that sense, that was really where
collaboration outside of Bell Labs. had to come in
- for things like X Windows, and so on, to become
a standard ?
So, were you reasonably cool about that at Bell Labs.?
You didn't feel that you ought to be totally dominating
this field?
>> BWK: I don't think - I certainly didn't care in
the slightest
there were people around me who, I think,
thought that X was very big, very
complicated - and perhaps unnecessarily so.
I know that Rob Pike, in particular, did
some really good work with overlapping
bitmap graphics so that if you have , y'know,
two windows on a screen and you do something
with them then you get a very efficient, rapid,
update and he
did some of the very first work on that
- very efficient algorithms - that I guess
eventually found their way into X.
And so there were people interested in
bit-blit, the technical things of bit mapping.
But I had drifted out of that at that
point, so I didn't pay much attention to it.
>> DFB: I think I've hogged the line of
questioning for far too long, Brian,
So, actually, cameramean Sean - Computerphile
people will know - is
expert at shouting questions, as well as doing
filming. So, over to you, Sean!